es tiempo de repasar la información
económica en france 24 para ello
contamos de nuevo con nuestro compañero
luís méndez luis y buenas noches y
bienvenidos vamos a comenzar con las
tensiones entre rusia y ucrania porque
también han afectado a han afectado a la
economía así es rodrigo de acuerdo con
la publicación de economía la situación
está generando presión en el valor de
algunas materias primas la publicación
entre una serie de commodities hace
referencia al trigo un producto
consumido en gran parte del mundo y del
que ucrania y rusia en conjunto exportan
casi un tercio del suministro mundial
por otro lado de acuerdo con the new
york times' rusia como productor de
petróleo y gas ha generado un aumento en
los precios de estos durante los últimos
días adicionalmente hemos visto que la
atención ha generado agitación en los
mercados mundiales pero los países
siguen presionando de alguna manera y
por ello eeuu anunció sanciones hacia la
empresa que trabaja en el proyecto nord
stream 2
esto es una tubería de gas que llevaría
gas desde rusia hasta alemania cuyo
proyecto terminado pero que no ha
recibido la licencia para operar y de
acuerdo con el ministro de economía
alemán robert sabe que podría
representar casi el 70 por ciento de las
entregas totales a alemania de el gas
pero en este caso por el momento otros
representantes del gobierno alemán
manifiestan que la suspensión dada por
alemania no generará un impacto debido a
que el proyecto todavía no está en
funcionamiento pero en cuanto a las
sanciones estadounidenses escuchamos que
fue lo que dijo el portavoz del
departamento de estado
al actuar junto con los alemanes como lo
hicimos nos hemos asegurado de que ésta
sea una inversión de 11 mil millones de
dólares que ahora es un trozo de acero
en el fondo del mar yonkers tío a ser
jeannette balmer sí pero rodrigo también
hubo palabras de ursula von der leyen
porque rusia sabemos que es un proveedor
de gas al continente europeo pero
escuchemos que dijo la presidenta de la
comisión europea tras la ascensión ante
la jce rusia ha instrumentalizado la
energía durante el último mes
y años para presionar no solo ucrania
sino también a la unión europea y ahora
estamos realmente decididos a salir de
la dependencia del gas de rusia las gas
louis nos vamos ahora hasta china porque
ha implementado medidas para aumentar la
producción de 'el oleaginosas así es el
anuncio fue dado a conocer el día de hoy
prevé entre otras cosas un aumento en la
producción de soya de acuerdo con el
documento central número 1 de este año o
el equivalente a la política agraria se
busca garantizar la política alimentaria
del país para llevar a cabo este plan
las autoridades señalaron que entre
otras cosas para mejorar los subsidios
para los agricultores los van a guiar en
el noreste de china establecerán una
base de producción principal para
plantar más soya y promover tecnología
de cultivos intercalados de soya y maíz
la soya es uno de los pocos cereales
para los que chinas depende en gran
medida de las importaciones con una tasa
de autosuficiencia del menos del 20 por
ciento el año pasado la importación
total fue de
96.5 millones de toneladas en eeuu y
brasil fueron los que más exportaron a
ese país
háblanos ahora de la empresa
mercadolibre que registró ganancias en
el último trimestre de 2021 es el mayor
market place el latinoamericano y pese a
los múltiples desafíos que tuvo que
hacer frente a lo largo del año pasado
logró resultados récord de un
crecimiento fuerte y sostenido de las
principales métricas esto por segundo
año consecutivo la compañía reportó que
sus ingresos netos en el período fueron
de
2100 millones de dólares es decir un 60
punto 5 por ciento más que el último
trimestre del año anterior y desde
argentína louis llegan buenas noticias
económicas y es que la actividad
económica en ese país se presentó un
alza en diciembre en comparación con el
mes de noviembre de 0.9 por ciento y
acumuló el pasado año un crecimiento de
2.3 por ciento que le permite salir de
la recesión que viene arrastrando desde
el 2018 hasta el 2020 con el avance
logrado en diciembre el indicador sumó
diez meses consecutivos de alza
interanual es
louis vamos con las bolsas dinos qué
dicen los indicadores los indicadores
por supuesto que están alterados están
mostrando números negativos en eeuu por
toda esta atención entre rusia y ucrania
a lo largo de lo que llevamos de semana
una situación que también se presentó en
los mercados europeos y de asia
principalmente el nikkei japonés que
mostraron números negativos américa
latina cerró con un balance mixto a lo
largo de la jornada muchísimas gracias
luis hasta aquí esta información
económica en france 24 sigan conectadas
[Música]